no Mary was not nice abrasive is not
enough of a word to explain what Mary
was to a few of us children specifically
Mr wives star Peyton Brown seemingly
accuses Mary of child abuse
does it move past verbal or oh it moves
so far past verbal verbal uh basically
stops existing the son of Cody and
Christine makes the confession about the
alleged abuse on a YouTube live with
John Yates where he makes claims about
Mary's treatment toward him and his
siblings so when you hear the stories of
like you know Mary being abrasive and um
when you guys are in the big giant house
together in Utah right like so that's
all true Mary was like kind of just mean
abrasive and kind of mean are not strong
enough words
they are not aggressive enough words
ET has reached out to Mary and TLC the
network that airs Sister Wives for
comment elsewhere in the live stream
Peyton alleges that sometimes Mary took
things too far Mary was not nice earlier
it was said that
um it's theorized that Mary was abrasive
and something else and I said that those
two words were not harsh enough and not
Advanced enough
abrasive is not enough of a word to
explain what Mary was to a few of us
children specifically does it move past
verbal or oh it moves so far past verbal
verbal uh basically stopped existing we
were never safe around her did your did
your dad know that not for several years
on the flip side Peyton credits Robin
his dad's only remaining wife for
helping them get out of a situation he
claims was abusive I will never hate
Robin
because she opened several eyes
she opened several eyes
and because of that I will never hate
her after having experienced negative
relationship she knew how to find other
negative relationships Robin
probably saved several of our Lives not
definitely but very maybe we've made
sort of promises to you know children
kind of things so we're always checking
that and making sure that our family is
complete as for how Peyton and his
siblings feel about Mary now I don't
talk to her ever most of us don't
there's a couple that do her daughter
Gwendolyn and as for Peyton's mom
Christine we know she no longer has
relationship with her former sister wife
I won't really be having that much to do
with Mary so much you know I wish her
the best to wish her all the happiness
in the world of course and whatever she
needs I hope she gets that I just don't
see that there's a friendship for us
these allegations against Mary come just
days after she and Cody announced they
are permanently terminating their
marriage after a decade of trying to
work things out he says no I don't
consider myself married to Mary
like he just made the decision I said to
him then if that's where we are don't
you think that we should address that
publicly and he said no I don't want to
address it
I don't want to address I don't want
that to be out there publicly because I
don't want that judgment and now that
it's officially out the former couple
released a joint statement to update
fans writing quote in light of a recent
unapproved press release we feel
compelled to share our own truth in our
own way and in our own timing we're
trying to be honest about how we feel
Cody and Mary also noted they're
committed to kindness and respect toward
each other and to all members of their
family
foreign